and then comes the russell wilson
interview with dan patrick on tuesday
and everything gets turned upside down
peter king joins us for today's edition
of pro football talk live on peacock
series xm211 nbc five on peacock series
xm211 nbcsn sky sports nfl and wherever
you get your podcast good morning peter
crazy week and we're going to try to
make sense of all of it in the next two
hours if that's even possible
well mike i'll tell you i was surprised
when i heard that because as you well
know
having interviewed russell wilson 400
times which you have
um
has he ever once said anything even
remotely slightly controversial
or even remotely slightly challenging to
the status quo
in seattle not not really and so that's
why this one
opened my eyes a little bit it did
surprise me and it says
it obviously says that russell wilson is
not entirely happy with the status quo
in seattle
and the follow-up on wednesday from dan
patrick was that the powers that be in
seattle not entirely happy with russell
wilson's decision to break so far from
character i mean this guy was
the consummate company man his entire
career he was resented by teammates he
was made fun of by teammates for being
the ultimate company man with the go
hawks every time he talked to anybody
anything related to the team it was the
go hawk sign off and the sense that he
was like so many franchise quarterbacks
over the years have been peter a guy who
is essentially the the liaison to
management who's in the locker room he's
the guy that's there on behalf of the
coaching staff in the front office to
make sure everyone does what they're
supposed to do and he broke from that in
a very sudden and abrupt way and i've
said all week long we're going to look
back on that interview as the moment
where
what it means to be a franchise
quarterback may have changed
fundamentally in the nfl as we see this
evolution become a revolution where
quarterbacks behave far differently than
they ever have
well mike you know so much occurs to me
when you say that um and i'll say this
that
tom brady i believe amiably amiably
really affected what happened inside the
tampa bay buccaneers this year
no one truly believes that the antonio
brown signing in late october was only
the decision of management and the
coaching staff
that was something that tom brady
pushed very hard
internally and basically told the
organization listen i give me
give me the responsibility
i'll take the responsibility i'll take
care of antonio brown
and you know what mike he did
and i you know we don't know what
happened inside the team the whole year
but antonio brown was a church mouse
this year
you know there was never any problem
with antonio brown
so
so it but and and then on the other side
there's another guy who's never
in his entire college and pro football
career
been anything but overly praised
and that's desean watson
and
mike we're going to find out if deshaun
watson can take the heat
because there's going to be some heat
this off season and i believe there's
going to be quite a bit of heat on
desean watson because
i don't think the houston texans are
going to go quietly into the night on
this i think they're basically going to
draw the line and say if you want to
play football you'll play for us now
will that last until the season who
knows i don't know nick casario's never
had to do this either cal mcnair's never
had to do this
but but i think you're right we are in a
different era of quarterbacking where
a guy like russell wilson just doesn't
sit back and and take what he perceives
are
uh incorrect building blocks with this
team
and both of the things you mentioned we
can pull back into the russell wilson
situation first of all the texans have
to be thrilled that this has dominated
the cycle for the past few days because
they found a way
to get the desean watson story off the
top of the stack and antonio brown
who was the other team
that was most commonly linked yeah the
ravens kind of sort of but the
organization didn't really want him and
i'm not sure lamar jackson and hollywood
brown really wanted him they just were
kind of saying what they were saying
because they know him and they like him
russell wilson really wanted him and the
seahawks made no effort to go get
antonio brown not that antonio brown
became randy moss 2007 but antonio brown
was a good soldier didn't create
problems contributed to the cause and
tom brady wanted him and tom brady got
him and i think the brady experience is
what is causing so many of these other
quarterbacks to say
why am i just going to act like an
employee
look at what tom brady did they handed
him the keys to the car in tampa bay and
now i want to have some of that same
influence and russell wilson is either
going to get it from the seahawks or
he's going to get it somewhere else i
was curious after everything that's
transpired over the past few days peter
whether or not at the core
there is in seattle the thing that
happened several weeks back in houston
the request
for a trade i'm told that that hasn't
happened yet but that all things are
fluid still between russell wilson and
the seahawks so i can't rule out that
it's going to happen i think maybe
what russell wilson's trying to do is
sufficiently agitate the seahawks enough
so they just trade him without a request
but i think that's the next thing to
watch will this manifest itself
in the seahawks not just hanging up the
phone when people call but actually
having the conversation as to whether or
not they'll trade russell wilson
know i doubt they would right now mike
but i do think
that uh
i don't think that's out of the question
just remember one thing
you know john schneider
you know learned at the
uh you know learned in the classroom of
ron wolf
and ron wolf basically always had this
attitude that you know there's going to
be firestorms there's going to be
problems there's going to be issues
and you know let the players play let
the coaches coach and let me pick the
players
that's the way it was in green bay how
would you like to be aaron rodgers one
of the greatest quarterbacks of all time
sitting at home having no idea that
jordan loved
uh was go that they were gonna pick a
quarterback in the first round this year
now did he get a call in the first round
while this happened maybe
but he didn't know
leading up to it that they were going to
draft jordan love
and so
that is sort of
you know if you if you look at the
personnel guy the pure personnel guy
in the nfl right now a guy like john
schneider that is the way they run their
team now mighty have to change he might
but mike you know i think this is about
one other thing too okay
dan patrick interviewed russell wilson
you know right after he was in miami or
in tampa at the super bowl
now i didn't watch the game on
on sunday night i was at the game
and
only occasionally do you really see
stuff on tv
and at one point i looked up and there's
russell wilson
with his wife in roger goodell's box and
even though he's got a mask on he looks
absolutely glum
you know and and i and i looked at that
and to me
the the words on russell wilson's face
were
i am miserable not making this game and
i look out on this field right now and i
see tom brady
and tom brady goes into a place
that has everything in place for him to
win a championship
and why can't i be in a place like that
you know i've done everything this team
has asked me to do why can't i be in a
place like that
so look
we'll see what happens in the coming
weeks but i really think that is what is
going through russell wilson's mind
right now
six years after it was tom brady versus
russell wilson brady with the patriots
wilson obviously still with the seahawks
and you know since that game super bowl
49 the seahawks haven't made it past the
divisional round in the nfc playoffs
meanwhile every year but one brady at
least gets to the conference
championship game he's won multiple
additional super bowls since then he's
won three more since then if my math is
correct and it rarely is it's just
amazing to think that this is where we
are right now with these two guys and
the the confidence slash delusion slash
hubris of an nfl quarterback is that i'm
the best it's just like the scottie
miller thing i'm faster than tyreek hill
that's how you have to be wired so
russell wilson thinks he's better than
tom brady he has to think that to
achieve at a high level so if he
genuinely believes that peter it has to
be tormenting him
of the thing that russell wilson is
stuck with one of nine years into his
career
you know mike if you sort of extrapolate
this story what would be fair market
value for russell wilson
i thought about that a lot this week
and
i keep hearing people say
when deshaun watson trade offers get
thrown out oh my god that's too much
like i said somewhere a couple of weeks
ago if it does come to this
i trade your existing quarterback plus
four ones for deshaun watson
and i was roundly shouted down
but but look
this is the point that i would make
about that all right
you have one job as an nfl franchise you
know what that job is it's not to hire a
great coach not to hire a great gm it's
to find a franchise quarterback
okay
you will have a chance
if you have a franchise quarterback
if you don't
you will you could very well be the new
england patriots of 2020
you could be a a lot of coaches in nfl
history who have a crap quarterback
situation
or maybe not enough talent and you're
just not good enough and that is why
i'll work on all the other stuff
we'll make all the other stuff we'll
we'll get it all to work okay
but give me the franchise quarterback
and that's why
if you said to me you have no ones
until 2025
and your incumbent quarterback let's say
sam darnold
is gone you have no ones your next four
ones are gone all right and with the
jets it's different because they got two
this year you know and obviously two two
next year
but what i'm saying is four ones
plus sam darnold if i'm the jets i do it
in an absolute heartbeat for a very
simple reason you now have solved the
problem
that has faced your franchise since
broadway joe namath was on the cover of
sports illustrated
yeah absolutely and it's been 50 years
since the jets have had that quarterback
and had that kind of level of
achievement and i think the jets would
make sense if that's something that
robert salah who has extensive
experience defending against russell
wilson would want to do i mean that's
part of what we find out if the seahawks
start taking these calls seriously we
found out fairly quickly what the rest
of the nfl thinks of matthew stafford
what does the rest of the nfl think of
russell wilson is he indeed being held
back by the seattle organization can you
run the offense through him and get a
patrick mahomes level of achievement out
of him on a regular basis if you make
him the centerpiece of your offense he
surely believes that now 2020 was kind
of strange because it started as let
russ cook and then the defenses caught
up with the offense so was it brian
schottenheimer was it pete carroll was
it russell wilson you almost won't be
able to tell until you see russell
wilson somewhere else where he is the
guy through whom the offense runs but
peter whether it's three first-round
picks whether it's four whatever it
takes and maybe sam darnold for russell
wilson plus multiple first-round draft
picks would get it done
but
if it's moving in that direction
that is a couple of years ago before
russell got his latest contract that
paid a market value of 35 million a year
he was linked to the new york giants and
there's that new york connection with
his wife ciara who maybe would like to
be in a market like that maybe russell
would thrive in a market like that he's
so good with the media he's in seattle
which kind of gets forgotten in the
greater nfl scheme of things
it makes a ton of sense for russell
wilson to be in new york and it makes a
ton of sense for the jets to consider it
and that would be the thing that finally
would sell out the stadium assuming that
fans will be back this year sell the
psls do all the things the jets have
struggled to do
in metlife stadium since they entered it
with the giants a decade ago
mike i want to i'm going to take just a
slight left turn here and i'm going to
talk a little bit more about what
russell wilson must be feeling i want to
take you to
very late in the second quarter
in the super bowl tyron matthew
interferes with
mike evans in the end zone and the ball
goes to the one-yard line
and whether or not you agree with the
interference which i do think it was
interference
but there at the one yard line
brady's at the line of scrimmage and
he's calling out the play and all of a
sudden timeout kansas city takes a time
out to discuss exactly what's going on
at that moment
great camera work by cbs right here
because they capture
tom brady
waving something off from the sidelines
and i couldn't tell because jim nance
and tony romo didn't talk about it but
they're waving it off and so
i made a call yesterday and i asked what
was going on when brady was saying
uh basically no no no no and he held up
five he held up his hands five five
okie five
and so i found out what happened
byron leftwich was going to call a
different play because this is spy
versus spy mike
and this is the defense basically
changing what it's doing
once it sees
what tampa is going to do and so at that
moment
leftwich starts to call a play into
brady's helmet i i think he starts to
call a play into brady's helmet and
brady goes no no no no no no same i
think he said same same same
and so the only reason i bring that up
now
is because
that was the play the tom brady fired
that bb into antonio brown's gut
where he does the the little move around
uh tyron matthew touchdown now it's 21-6
at halftime totally different game i
only bring that up because i assume that
any quarterback in the nfl who's
watching that play said my god
one of the big plays of your season
you're at the one yard line you can get
another touchdown and you know what
happened tom brady told the coaches i
got this i got this you guys that were
running the play that was called before
and they ran the play and it was a
touchdown and this was no
this is not deep and dark
it is simply sometimes a quarterback
knows exactly what he should be doing on
the field and if russell wilson saw that
and i bet he did if russell wilson saw
that he's got to be thinking man look at
the power that tom brady has and he's
out there winning a super bowl
now i'm not trying to gratuitously pull
another quarterback into this
conversation but as you're explaining
that i'm thinking of aaron rodgers with
that fourth and goal from the eight in
the nfc championship oh that's great
he just accepted the fact that out comes
the field goal team and there's not a
damn thing i can do about it and what
freedom tom brady has and whether it's
wilson whether it's rogers
these guys who are stuck at one super
bowl win and they're seeing tom brady
piling them up and tom brady now
empowered by the buccaneers to basically
take over the offense and do what he
sees fit and bring in guys he wants to
be there that's the kind of thing that i
think is going to drive both rogers and
wilson crazy this jets thing has me
percolating peter because i'll tell you
this
the idea of russell wilson moving on
from the seahawks is not new
and and i've mentioned it from time to
time and seahawks fans initially have
shouted me down and i haven't pushed it
as hard
as i could have based on what i've been
hearing but the one team that i always
hear
when it relates to russell wilson a
potential trade is the dallas cowboys
but now you got me thinking about the
jets because as matt casey mentioned in
my ear after we talked about the jets a
minute ago great way for the seahawks
and the jets to do a transaction that
would entail the jamal adams first round
pick going back to seattle hey we got
two first round picks for a guy who
didn't really want to be here let's just
call it this let's call it jamal adams
plus a first round pick or two for
russell wilson we would do that trading
a heartbeat absolutely we would have
done that trade in a heartbeat and so
let's put a package together premises
not quite exactly that though mike
it isn't quite exactly that because
think of it
it would have to be sam darnold plus
uh
you know plus basically jamal adams
you know
and you'd have to i would think you'd
have to give at least two ones
in in this scenario because if you are
giving seattle back
its picks you're basically giving them
back uh two mid to late round ones okay
but you're also giving them the second
pick in the draft
right so in a in an odd odd way
if they got sam darnold can you imagine
what they would do with that second pick
in the draft i'll bet you 100 bucks that
john schneider would take that tackle
from oregon
you know and then finally the tackle who
russell wilson was looking for for nine
years
would show up the day after he left the
building and it would just be kind of a
weird weird irony
and think about that package from
the seahawks perspective if you get
offered
sam darnold the second overall pick
and the two first-round picks that you
sent for jamal adams and and if if the
jets have to throw in a fourth one to
make it happen so be it let's say it's
basically jamal adams sam darnold and
two first round picks including the
second overall pick how in the hell
would the seahawks say no to that and
i'm starting to think maybe that's too
much for the jets to give up
but again what they've done is they've
spun their wheels
for the last 50 years looking for
another franchise quarterback and they
haven't been able to find one so
if i'm the jets i seriously would
consider making that kind of offer and
it becomes borderline offer the seahawks
can't refuse peter
i don't know if the seahawks would start
to think at that point
but
i also know this mike
if i were joe douglas
uh as good as russell wilson is i'd
rather have a quarterback who's seven
years younger
and so
that offer first is going to the houston
texans if it hasn't already gone there
well here's the other side of it too
russell wilson through his agent mark
rogers who has one nfl client and always
drives a hard bargain you're gonna have
to pay russell wilson
much more
than what deshawn watson is currently
making russell wilson is going to try to
get top of market money he's gotten two
prior times top of market money close to
it he was just behind aaron rodgers when
he did his first four year extension he
became the highest paid player in nfl
history when he got his most recent one
at 35 million a year in new money now
you got patrick mahomes at 45 that's
part of what you're going to have to
factor into this if you're the jets
you're going to have to pay russell
wilson and his agent is going to push
you very hard to do it he comes through
the door making a mere 19 million
dollars in salary for this year so the
contract itself not a difficult thing
for a new team to take on what's
difficult and what's challenging is the
contract you're going to buy the next
time around and when is the next time
around is it this year is it next year
is that the year after those are things
that whoever would trade for russell
wilson needs to consider as well because
you're swapping those low-cost
round picks for a guy that's going to
cost you
top of market money
but you know what i would do mike in
this particular case if i'm mark rogers
and i'm russell wilson
i would say listen
you know let's just have a little uh
you know one an honorable agreement you
can't sign anything about this or
anything
um
you know there just has to be the
understanding that when the salary cap
kicks over 200 million we got to redo my
contract
that has to be
that would in my opinion be a logical
way to do it because i would not want to
show up in florian park new jersey
eating up half of the gigantic amount of
cap space that the jets are going to
have i wouldn't want to show up doing
that because that prevents you from
surrounding russell wilson with great
players or better players i should say
or or do the thing that i've been
arguing for years now the jets refused
to do it with darrell rivas in 2010
guarantee russell wilson a percentage of
the cap period whatever it is 17 16.2
whatever it is that's what he gets every
year so there always is that remaining
84 cents on the dollar again whatever
they decide is going to be the number
that's what's there to put the team
around him and and part of it too look
you give up all that stuff for russell
wilson your gallery expectation you're
getting the guy
who wants to be the tom brady who waves
off the play who brings in the guys he
wants otherwise you just end up in the
same spot the seahawks are in and before
you know it russell wilson's going to be
on dan patrick talking about
the concerns he has with his current
team
yeah and mike
i'll tell you what i think this is going
to end with russell wilson staying in
seattle but
i do think
there's going to have to there's going
to be several meetings of the minds
and you know
curiously absent in this honestly is
ownership
where is jody allen in this
you know i understand that she's
reticent that she's a private person i
and i get it i get it but when you own
an nfl team
it's not like owning a private
you know a private business not like
owning a hardware store you know you are
in the spotlight
and again look i don't know what her
relationship with wilson is
but where is she
she should be uh you know starting to
have some conversations about this
because the most valuable asset in her
empire basically sporting empire is
russell wilson and he apparently is not
happy so
do something about it step forward do
something be involved
uh
you know i i don't know those are the
things i'm i'm thinking about mike that
that the organization has to be involved
you can't just always say hey john
schneider fix this let's let the
organization go at it too
by all appearances peter and i've been
trying to get to the bottom of that
because for as quiet
and understated and unassuming as paul
allen was
his sister is even more of the same
she's nowhere to be seen she's nowhere
to be found this is all pete carroll
that's the impression this is pete's
call whatever pete wants to do that's
what it's going to be
and
who knows look peter i initially thought
when this all came up that
next year is when it all comes to a head
that the the cap charge pre-june one for
a trade 39 million dollars in dead money
for the seahawks they're not going to
entertain that now you could do the
trade june 2 and make it 13 this year
and 26 next year with no off season
program what's he really missing so i
think if it does happen it would be
something that becomes official on or
after june 2. but even then are you
ready to do it this year do you want to
try to fix it do you want to give it a
year and see if it works with shane
waldron do you want to let russ be
involved with free agency in the draft
you know a lot of this depends on what
the seahawks choose to do and all we've
heard the past three days as it relates
to the seahawks is the report from dan
patrick that the seahawks aren't happy
with russell wilson okay fine they're
not happy what does that mean does that
mean they're at a point of no return or
does that mean they're gonna hash it out
and they're gonna figure out how to make
it work for at least one more year maybe
two maybe three maybe more
and that's what nobody knows right now
but i think that
uh
unless
some team like like the jets gets very
aggressive
in this
i think
that at some point
schneider and pete carroll
are going to try to address some of
wilson's concerns
even though
excuse me even though they are very much
this is not the way that john schneider
has ever operated in his career and i
think he has to determine
is it worth it to try to make peace
to change
uh at this point in his
what has been a very successful nfl
career
uh is he willing to change the way he
does things somewhat
um you know to accommodate his
quarterback and we'll see i really don't
know this is an interesting story mike
they may just say hey listen
shut up and go to work they may do that
who knows we'll see but it doesn't
strike me that pete carroll who is
always a hey don't worry be happy hey
we're all one big happy family blah blah
blah
that you know i mean he was always able
to bury
the rancor the anger
of marshawn lynch
and the team divisiveness
of marshawn lynch he was always able to
push that to the side
but i don't know that this is going to
be uh the same deal this is the leader
of your franchise not some
petulant uh counterculture guy
who really you know he
it's it's not that he wasn't important
to the team he was very important but
he's not the quarterback of the team
either
like deshawn watson and for that matter
tom brady russell wilson has a no trade
clause in his contract which gives him
the ability to veto any potential trade
that the seahawks would try to engineer
if he doesn't want to go to say for
example jacksonville i'm fascinated by
the possibility of the jaguars saying
we'll give you the trevor lawrence pick
and we'll take russell wilson would
russell wilson say i'll take
jacksonville maybe he would maybe he
wouldn't but the folks at points bet put
together the odds earlier this week for
the destination if not seattle the jets
aren't on the board
maybe they should be how are they just
not on the board i i don't know that's
maybe that's saying that's maybe maybe
that's a maybe that's a bet we need to
place but the the las vegas raiders
currently at the top at plus 450. i
don't know about that one again i i i
have heard i guess points bet is is is
is located in las vegas
i i've but i've heard over and over
again the dallas cowboys mike mayak is
telling everybody everybody we're not
trading car period stop
i mean yeah this is a silly graphic
silly and and i i've heard that the
raiders aren't trading derek carr but i
think with john gruden you can never
rule out anything and if there would be
an opportunity to get russell i wouldn't
put a number one on the list is all i'm
saying yeah i i don't disagree with you
and i'm surprised the jets aren't on
there and maybe the jets should be on
there you've sold me on the jets the
question is would russell wilson be sold
on the jets and ultimately look here's
the thing that we don't know we don't
know what robert sala privately thinks
of russell wilson from the two or three
times per year that he's had
to to come up with a defense
and and how do you handle russell wilson
how much does he compare to patrick
mahomes to tom brady how much are you
spending your time scared to death at
night when you're trying but the
question is mike like that isn't the
question russell wilson
that's not the question
you know whether you might like patrick
mahomes better than russell wilson is
totally
or any of these other quarterbacks that
doesn't matter the question is do you
like justin fields better than russell
wilson
you know do you like sam darnold better
than russell wilson that's the issue and
the issue is
first of all i can't believe that robert
sala would not
very much aggressively want to go after
russell wilson
i mean look they have had some great
games over the years and russell
wilson's won a lot of those great games
over the years so i'd be very surprised
if salah wouldn't be saying to joe
douglas go get him if it was possible
and and i think salah was in seattle at
one point along the way too so he's had
access yeah he was russell wilson
at
yeah so he's been there he's done that
he knows who he's getting
yeah you just have to be all in on the
player to the point where you're willing
to give up everything you have to give
up to get him and that you're willing to
stand in the shoes that it's going to
take to be his employer going forward
you're going to be paying him a lot of
money and you got to be willing to give
him a seat at the table are you willing
to do that are you willing to empower
your quarterback tom brady style because
at the core
that's what this is
this is this dawn of a new age of
franchise quarterback sparked by tom
brady's move to tampa bay and ability to
win a super bowl right away that is
increasing the pressure the anxiety the
stress for guys like russell wilson and
to a lesser extent aaron rodgers he's
keeping his mouth shut but i'm sure he's
watching this too peter because we're
seeing what happens when a team says to
a quarterback
we are deferring to you
and we're going to let you have
influence over how we run our team at a
time when all the other teams are stuck
in that mindset of
yeah we want you
to kind of behave like a manager among
your teammates but when it's time for
the management meeting you're not
invited
yeah i i agree with you mike i i just i
guess
my overarching overriding point in this
is
that
if i was an nfl general manager or i was
running an nfl franchise
and my quarterback was
a c minus quarterback
and or whatever you would call sam
darnold right now not saying that it's
his fault
okay
but his performance is not great
and if that was my situation
and there was even a whiff in the air
that i could get
a great quarterback on my team
i do exactly what the new york giants
did
uh way back in i forget when it was
maybe around 1968 or something when they
traded two ones and two twos for fran
tarkinton
and
and and he wasn't at the level
of say a russell wilson or a desean
watson he was a very good pro
quarterback but the giants didn't have a
quarterback
and fran tarkinton gave him one for i
think he was there five years
fran tarkinton gave them
a chance to win every sunday
russell wilson would give the new york
jets a chance to win every sunday
while they built their team up
even though they wouldn't have
three or four of the very high picks
that they wish they did and peter
coincidentally yesterday was the 54th
anniversary of the day that fran
tarkenton informed the vikings he would
no longer play for them laying the
foundation for the trade even though it
was a norm van broglin fran tarkin and
thing and norm van brocklin had been
fired
tarkin and still didn't want to play for
the vikings got traded to the giants and
of course six years after that got
traded back to the vikings and made it
to three super bowls
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports